all right we're here in Miami rolling
through interview after interview and
joining us now God who made a huge
impact on our season with the Green Bay
Packers they finally realized what it
means
bring in some guys via free agency you
make a difference a Terry Smith agency
thank you thank you for having me
most definitely the man first off this
we're on the field in Chicago opening
oil NBC all right like no I just think
the first time we saw you and Preston on
the field together we went oh wait this
deep that's gonna be different this year
and you felt that right away
yes sir most definite I think we talked
about that you know when we first said
somehow he was gonna come in and change
the culture of the team and be leaders
right if you don't know about now man
from his past season man we did a great
job man at doing that at guys started to
become their self you know come to work
every day how far man and that energy
man led us to the championship game you
know we didn't pull it all play we went
far enough first year ma yeah yeah you
were one of the guys that Aaron Rodgers
singled out after the FA chip game yeah
the guys who came in brought leaders
just like football fun again for him
that's amazing I mean you weren't there
before a little compare it but what what
did you sense from Aaron Rodgers this
year to give you the impression he was
so happy with how everything is but I
feel like I got to come in and just be
yourself you know to be a dominant
player like I am man to come in and just
be that guy who brings joy to everybody
you know and uh it's not just the locker
room man it's the cafeterias man it's
the all of that from the trainer's the
whole whole right and they love it and I
think that's exactly what Aaron Rodgers
was talking about man that's why we've
been so good this year tell me about so
Aaron Rodgers love you yeah now you tell
me about Aaron Rodgers oh it's like to
be with him for the first year and I
love me too I think the first thing he
said when I first met him in the locker
room he was like man I'm just glad you
don't hit me you don't get a chance to
hit me so to have that man to have that
atmosphere with him man it's it's pretty
fun man and I'm just glad I get to play
with a legendary quarterback like a rose
yeah I mean we've talked about it a lot
like would like tell people when you
have a quarterback like that how it kind
of just gives the team confidence yeah I
mean a situation man
I could tell you this man he's calm
through everything right that's one
thing about race you didn't if you know
him yeah man he's just calm and when we
get in critical situation you don't
panic and I think that's a leader man
that brings a lot because you have a
lunch laughs I'm sorry you watch a young
guy so ya have a bunch of young guys man
to look up a guy like Aaron rosin myself
man is big and as you can see Manny
helped our team so much to shoot right
he always talks about having a scotch
after a game win or lose a happy scotch
or a bad scotch every parallel scotch
with Aaron Rodgers now you gonna hit
somebody's crazy man we actually did a
Halloween party man and he always said
it man the teams that drank together
wins together but that's one of the
story that I got from that yeah you all
right no the last game that's in and the
way you want yeah yeah I know we talked
all bouton all week like the 49ers
everybody like did you feel like some of
those schemes are different than like
what you saw earlier they were but at
the same time you know I was a pro man
you got to watch football man and then
one thing that they did man they schemed
us up very well we wasn't ready to play
football as a team right you know they
got to our edges and that's something
that me and Preston gotta do work on you
know all right
setting it it's better man because there
were certain situations to where the
ball bounced on the edge bander they had
a lot of yards that they gained off uh
so I feel like man knows it's refugees
gotta practice man and get better next
year how do you set the edge though yeah
okay like when Kittel doesn't block you
and then you're like wait I'm on the
edge and all sudden the full-back comes
around surprise yeah right it's just
it's the scheming just got another
football game I know I watched football
a lot man and I keying on a lot of
things but man it was just one of those
games where he was coming back you think
you probably cutting me but it's not now
he's aboard and now the ball bouncing
outside right in those situations like I
said we just got to work on in this
offseason man to get better as a team
yeah your coach Matt Lafleur had some
comments after the game that were pretty
eye-opening he had concerns about the
the lack of fire yeah perceived did you
perceive that as well in this past day
yeah yeah that's what I was telling man
we didn't come ready to play
if everybody was sleeping but I could
tell you for myself I wasn't ready to
play you know coming in the night before
who wasn't who wasn't ready to play
football I'd know that much because
three West Coast trips this year where
it seemed like you guys kind of sell
them at the wheel I manage this our
first shipment you got a look at it man
we got our first year GM first year head
coach man first year captive for myself
you know right we all knew it this man
and to be able to travel over that way
man I feel like you know if we just
leave a little bit earlier you know just
at the time I feel like I helped a whole
lot where everybody who travels and play
football yeah when you're in at that
moment and you know that in your heart
you're not feeling mm-hmm what you need
to feel what what take take me through
the mindset do you try to like start the
lawnmower yeah like what do I do it I
gotta bang my head against what do I do
to get myself ready I think I watched
one video it was this guy who was it
that he always gets left oh the guy in
Jacksonville throw over him he's a tree
trunks nice just be situations where you
got to know that's that's another thing
it's being a pro man you got to be
prepared and be ready to go play
football at all times and especially
when you know that it's a Sunday night
game world Sunday Monday night game so I
felt like man just to prepare I mean
during that game I wasn't ready so I
will try to get the guys to slap me on
my past nothing get me going you know
and so I could really get a proper you
know like I said that's something that
we have to work on and this offseason
they prepare for next season you make no
excuses which I really know about you
I've noticed that about you even going
back to Baltimore you kind of just like
take it on the chin like yeah people
want to play Mike Pettine for that last
game nah man you can't no no you can't
man I feel like I was a team man you got
to keep your team together man like I
said it's all of our first year together
right and we came so far man so I felt
like we all need to do nothing with
nobody Mary's got to keep closing close
keep closing man to place keep playing
man it will be like yeah you got the
Chiefs when they didn't have Patrick
mahomes yeah it was your impression of
the rest of the offense Wow pretty good
offense man hey they got you got to
receive as many other
thanks man they got the whole nine they
got offense defense and special change
so I feel like for them man when we
played them we we had no situations of
stopping the run and then making them
throw the ball because that's when we're
really effective as being Preston and
Kenny Clark
give me a quarterback so in those
situations for us just to stop the runs
and being like gaps I felt like was a
big thing for that game when we played
them
you got like a lean in the game like I'm
picking the Niners quietly said of our
team and then he's going chief because
he's believed in the mahomes magic and
all that song I don't know man I can say
the Chiefs might pull it off man just
because you you know they like I was
just telling they got the offense the
defense and special teams and they all
around the board man in certain
situations I feel like the 49ers if they
get a chance to get to the edges then
they gotta watch if they get away you're
not sure man I'm telling you man yeah I
wish I had opportunity to do that but
you know I learned from my mistakes man
and know that I can fix the mixture yeah
that's right attitude you know a lot of
guys would be tempted to come up with
different excuses and explanations that
I didn't do what I needed to do say I
didn't do what I need to do and I'm
gonna figure out for next year what I
need to do to make a difference yeah and
now the leader man I put that on the
table man and I tell all the younger
guys man you know put it on me because
we didn't prepare right you know it was
my first year as a captain and I'm still
learning myself but I also learned from
a lot of greats you know
Terrell Suggs you know Elvis do Merville
Eric Weddle
I had them type of guys around so I know
what it's gonna take
get us to where we need to be last thing
because I know you got more of a life
than we do all right I gotta ask you
about Lamar Jackson oh yeah cuz you got
to be around him for a year yeah were
you surprised I mean what just tell me
your outlook on that look man I knew
that was coming man I know he was gonna
lead that team to where they were you
know and where they had gotten to yeah
you know for me I was with him last week
down there and at the Pro Bowl and I was
like man I'm a thank you and it's game
and I got my opportunity to finally sack
a man and then I appointed to coach
Harbaugh man so it was all fun that oh
like I was there last year
yeah now second quarterback man yeah man
this is good for him man I'm happy for
him he's a young guy who's gonna do a
lot of great things in this in this
league yeah no doubt about it could be
in 55 Packers against the Ravens I'd pay
to see ya all right hey there's
congratulations thank you man that's
good luck
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports